[Music]
we typically think of ballet as
harmonious graceful and polished hardly
features that would trigger a riot but
at the first performance of Igor
Stravinsky's the Rite of Spring audience
members were so outraged that they
drowned out the orchestra accounts of
the event
include people hurling objects at the
stage challenging each other to fights
and getting arrested all on what started
as a sophisticated night at the ballet
first performed in May 1913 at the tail
traditions Alizee in Paris the Rite of
Spring is set in prehistoric times the
narrative follows an ancient pagan
community worshiping the earth and
preparing for the sacrifice of a woman
intended to bring about the change of
seasons but the ballet is much more
concerned with the violent relationship
between humans nature and culture than
with character or plot these themes
manifest in a truly upsetting production
which combines harsh music jerky dancing
and uncanny staging it opens with
dancers awakening to a solo bassoon
playing in an eerily high register this
gives way to discordant strings
punctured by unexpected pauses while the
dancers twitch to the music these
frightening figures enact the ballets
brutal premise which set audiences on
edge and shattered the conventions of
classical music in these ways and many
more the Rite of Spring challenged the
orchestral traditions of the 19th
century composed on the cusp of both the
First World War and the Russian
Revolution the Rite of Spring seeds with
urgency this tension is reflected in
varies formal experiments including
innovative uses of syncopation or
irregular rhythm a tonality or the lack
of a single key and the presence of
multiple time signatures
side these strikingly modern features
Stravinsky spliced in aspects of Russian
folk music a combination that
deliberately disrupted the expectations
of his sophisticated urban audience
this wasn't Stravinsky's first use of
folk music born in a small town outside
of st. Petersburg in 1882 Stravinsky's
reputation was cemented with the lush
ballet the Firebird based on a Russian
fairy tale this production was steeped
in Stravinsky's fascination with full
culture but he plotted a wilder project
in the Rite of Spring pushing folk and
musical boundaries to draw out the
rawness of pagan ritual Stravinsky
brought this reverie to life in
collaboration with artist Nicholas
Roerich roerich was obsessed with
prehistoric times he had published
essays about human sacrifice and worked
on excavations of Slavic tombs in
addition to set and costume design for
the Rite of Spring he drew from Russian
medieval art and peasant garments to
create costumes that hung awkwardly on
the dancers bodies were except them
against vivid backdrops of primeval
nature full of jagged rocks looming
trees and nightmarish colors along with
its dazzling sets and searing score the
original choreography for the Rite of
Spring was highly provocative this was
the doing of legendary dancer Vaslav
Nijinsky who developed dances to rethink
the roots of movement itself although
Stravinsky later expressed frustration
with Majin skis demanding rehearsals and
single-minded interpretations of the
music his choreography proved as
pioneering as Stravinsky's composition
he contorted traditional ballet to both
the awe and horror of his audience many
of whom expected the refinement and
romance of the genre the dancing in the
Rite of Spring is agitated and uneven
with performers cowering writhing and
leaping about as if possessed often the
dancers are not one
the music but rather seemed to struggle
against it the gin ski instructed them
to turn their toes inwards and land
heavily after jumps often off the beat
for the final frenzied seen a woman
dances herself to death two loud bangs
and jarring strings the ballet ends
abruptly on a harsh punting chord today
the Rite of Spring remains as chilling
as its controversial debut but the
shockwaves of the original work continue
to resound and inspire you can hear
Stravinsky's influence in modern jazz as
dueling rhythms folky classical music
and even film scores for horror movies
which still elicit a riotous audience
response in the third act of Swan Lake
the Black Swan spins on one pointed foot
32 times find out the physics behind the
hardest move in ballet in this video
[Music]